Yeah. Hi everyone, I'm Pete. I'm Daniel. And we're software engineers at Portswiger,
working on our cross product AR offering called Burp AI. We're talking about the story of what's
gone into its evolution and some of the techniques you can use to build agentic systems and improve
them for web application security. So what we're going to show you today then? Well, first we're
going to cover why we think AI in AppSec and Burp is a reasonable idea. Then we're going to go over
how the Burp AI launch went, what we learned from it, what we learned from the initial features.
Next, the approach and techniques to consider when building and improving an agentic system
and the importance of tools and how the model context protocol or MCP can help.
And then finally, how you can use and experiment with AI to improve your own workflows.
And we sprinkled in a couple of short demos throughout the presentation as well.
So it's pretty clear that right now in 2025, everyone from Fortune 500 companies to high school
students working from their bedrooms are building products of AI. And these range from simple
chatbots to fully automated systems for creating websites without touching any code.
So what makes AppSec interesting for AI? Well, AI has proved to be extremely
disruptive in the software development industry, with workflows evolving to incorporate these tools
and benefit from the productivity gains. And this is translating over into the cybersecurity domain.
So the ISC2 pulse survey showed that 30% of security teams have already integrated AI tools,
with another 42% actively evaluating or testing them. And crucially, 70% of adopters report increased
effectiveness. And AppSec is a domain in which there is like a wealth of opportunities beyond chatbots.
Once we recognised the potential, we went about launching Burp AI with a set of five features.
And the idea was to cast the net wide addressing different pain points where AI could provide immediate value,
solving problems that are much more difficult to address without AI.
And then after the release, when we looked at usage trends and gathered feedback, one feature stood out.
That was Explorer Issue. It was quickly becoming the most popular.
And this confirmed our assumptions about where AI can make the biggest impact in web app security testing.
So to give a little bit of background on the Explorer Issue feature, it lets you take a scanner found issue
and dig deeper, uncovering more context and sometimes escalating the finding using tools such as Repeater and Intruder to interact further with the site.
And in practice, as the tool matured, we saw something interesting.
Many users were creating their own custom issues and running Explorer Issue on those.
And this gave us two key insights.
One, users wanted more control over the initial information being sent to the AI agent.
And two, they wanted to use the agent outside of scanner issues to get insights from other contexts.
So, ultimately, the power of features like Explorer Issue come down to its agentic approach.
An agent isn't just a one-shot prompt. It can perform an action, learn from the outcome, and adapt its direction of attack for the next step.
That iterative loop allows the AI to tackle harder problems more effectively and autonomously.
The agent can refine its strategy of each attempt just like a human tester would.
So that all sounds great.
Agentic AI systems seem really powerful for automating tedious or potentially complicated tasks.
But a natural follow-up question is, how do I make them better in my domain?
So the first instinct for many is to take the AI model at the center of your agentic system and improve and specialize it for your domain.
For those of you familiar with LLMs and Transformers, you may have heard of fine-tuning.
It's the process of updating the model weights with a task-specific training set.
In the best case, this can lead to a specialized model with the behavior you need.
For example, you might be able to get the model to adopt the right tone of voice, or handle domain-specific jargon,
or consistently perform a repetitive task with high accuracy.
In highly stable problem spaces, this can result in a model that outperforms a general-purpose model on that particular task.
However, in practice, fine-tuning has some significant drawbacks.
It can be difficult and labor-intensive to gather and prepare the necessary data.
Updating the weights on a cutting-edge LLM uses a tremendous amount of computational power,
and even after all of that, you're likely to end up with a reduction in the capability for general skills, such as tool-calling,
and you will have to repeat the process all over again if you migrate to a new foundation model.
Fine-tuning can also quickly become out of date,
and especially when the domain is changing as rapidly as it does in web app security testing.
This is an opening sentence from Rich Sutton's The Bitter Lesson,
and it still rings true when building agentic systems.
The biggest lesson that can be read from 70 years of AI research is that general methods
that leverage computation are ultimately the most effective and by a large margin.
So, when building agentic systems for a fast-moving domain such as web app pen testing,
this lesson is especially relevant.
Models change rapidly and new foundation models arrive with leaps in general capability.
If we invest too heavily in over-optimizing architectures, complex workflows, or custom fine-tunes
that don't scale with compute and foundation model improvements,
then we risk building brittle systems that can become obsolete in under a year.
So, the key takeaway is the sanity check where effort is being spent.
If a new workflow or structure only works for today's model,
or if it requires constant re-engineering, then it might not be worth the investment.
Cool, thanks Pete. So, I guess while taking all that into account, is there something else that we
can do when building these agentic pen testing systems?
So, yeah, instead of focusing on improving the LLM model at the core of the agent,
we can shift to something else that's much more flexible, the input that we actually feed that agent.
This encompasses everything from the user's prompts to the tools that we provide the LLM,
creating a dynamic system that provides the right context in the right format at the right time.
This usually gives general purpose models everything they need to accomplish a wide variety of complex tasks.
The term recently coined for this is context engineering, and all of this information is used to produce the next output or tool call in the agentic loop.
So, one of the simplest and most powerful ways that you can actually give your agent high quality context is just through human interaction.
This often takes the form of a prompt, which you may be familiar with from popular tools such as ChatGPT.
Another way of gathering this human interaction can be achieved by allowing the agent to ask for it when it needs it as a tool call.
However, we need to be careful about when and how often we do this.
Every time the agent turns to a human for help, it introduces friction into the workflow.
And if it happens too frequently, it stops feeling like this magical intelligent assistant and starts feeling like you're just manually performing the task yourself in a more clumsy way.
The principle is to maximize autonomy while reserving human input for high leverage interventions.
So, following on from these lessons that we learned as a team from the explore issue feature, we really wanted this agentic capability to be available to a wider audience and with more user control over the context.
Burp repeater is that next step and it's a tool that enables you to, sorry, Burp AI and repeater is that next step.
And repeater itself is a tool that enables you to modify and send an interesting HTTP or WebSocket message over and over.
It's perhaps the most popular and fundamental tool in Burp Suite.
Giving Burp users the ability to easily access an agentic AI system within the context of repeater really improves the flexibility of it and puts in a place which integrates smoothly with a wider range of workflows.
So, if you haven't used the Web Security Academy before, one, I recommend it.
And two, it's a free online collection of labs where you can learn and test your skills on a wide variety of realistic vulnerabilities.
So, I'm about to show you a quick demo of Burp AI and repeater completing a reflected XSS lab from the Web Academy to demonstrate sort of like the power of these agentic systems and how they work in practice.
So, let's see if this video will actually load for you guys.
Cool.
So, we're here in repeater.
You can see that I've already sent a request to the lab homepage and we have this new Burp AI button up in the top with a pre-written prompt here.
It does save your prompt if you close that pop-up so you don't have to leave it open.
And we include context from both the request and response when we're sending it to the LLM.
So, if you click over on that post, you're able to jump right over to the dashboard and see the running task.
And here's one that's run before with the exact same prompt.
So, it's going to be looking in the search parameter for reflection and it's going to try and exploit this and solve the lab.
So, it's going to go through that agentic loop that we talked about before where it's going to try something, observe what it's done, and reason about it so it can make its next action.
And here you can sort of see it working through how you would do this XSS lab, figuring out how it can escape the JavaScript string.
And eventually, it does actually figure out how to do it and how to deliver that payload.
And finally, we get the correct request to actually solve the lab.
And when we open up that tool call in the pop-out window, we can search for the solved command and we can see, oh, it has actually solved the lab.
So, at the top of each of these agentic flows, we get a task summary when it's done and that just gives you a little summary of what it's actually completed.
Cool.
So, that's Burp AI and Repeater.
Let me hop on back over here.
So, following on from this, tools are really the next critical part of context engineering for an agentic system.
The selection and capabilities of these tools that you provide can really make or break the effectiveness of that system.
They're how an agent interacts with the world and gathers information.
When developing tools for AI agents, it's best to understand how they affect your context and add safety guardrails, as well as adding controls for when tools are available in that context.
A significant challenge in the case of a tool like Repeater is how do you handle the response data returned from an HTTP request, which may be massive, while keeping the valuable information for the agent to use to work towards its goals.
So, when it comes to APIs for AI tools, Model Context Protocol, or MCP, immediately comes to mind.
Hopefully, some of you have heard of it, but if you haven't, it's a widely adopted API in the industry, and it's growing a large number of useful capabilities, and it kind of makes it the obvious choice for exposing tools to agents at the moment.
It's often analogized as the USB-C for AI.
It's a universal connector that makes it easy to connect your different AI platforms to external tools and data.
In the protocol, the MCP server provides the context.
That could be access to your burp tools, such as Repeater or Intruder, or something like the files on your computer.
And then the MCP client on the other end then pulls that context in so the AI can actually use it.
So, MCP has some really desirable capabilities built in, such as tool discovery and interoperability.
So, this means that agents can query which tools are available and what they can do without requiring hard-coded integrations.
It also supports continuous streams of data.
So, for security testing, this could enable long-running tasks, such as crawling or brute-forcing, where partial results can be consumed immediately by the agent.
And finally, it has fine-grained controls.
MCP lets tool providers declare what tools and actions are available.
For offensive tooling like burp, this creates an extra layer of assurance and control when exposing potentially destructive operations to those AI agents.
So, if you guys want to try out MCP with burp suite using your own AI client, I've released an open-source MCP server extension in the in-product extension market called the BAP Store.
It's available in both the burp suite community and pro versions, so it's not limited by a paywall or anything.
And it's still being improved, and we're happy to take new issues and PRs submitted on the GitHub repo.
So, here's a real quick demo of the MCP server extension being used in burp to perform a pretty simple operation of just changing the color theme.
There isn't actually a specific tool exposed by the MCP server for changing the theme,
but the AI is able to figure it out by reading the existing burp config and modifying the JSON in place.
I've also used it in the past to solve a wide variety of Web Academy labs,
and it also has assisted me in learning some web app pen testing concepts in burp.
So, at the moment, here's what I would recommend if you're really keen to start trying out AI-assisted workflows as a burp user.
One, try out the MCP server extension that I just showed you to get access to those burp tools and extend it with some external ones.
You can create your own sort of custom AI pen testing environment to interact with burp and any other tools that you use for your pen tests.
You can experiment with a wide range of contexts and tasks when using agentic systems, such as burp AI and repeater.
You might be surprised by the range of what they can do, so really push the limits and see if something that you don't expect it to be able to do is actually possible.
And if they suit your needs, non-agentic AI tools can also solve some of the more specific problems fairly consistently.
They're really common in people's workflows.
So, in terms of like the future of burp AI, we have a pretty exciting roadmap to announce soon, and we're looking forward to bringing AI into our DAS platform, which is more of like our enterprise offering.
And we also have some really cool capabilities that we're planning to add in the coming months across Burp Suite.
So, yeah, keep an eye out.
Thank you.